[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma était en fait la
soupe aujourd'hui non avec c'est énorme
légumes spécial spécial c'est moi on va
faire un potiron un potiron une
citrouille 2 ça c'est un juge de soupe
de souprayen voilà et une troisième
soupe vous avez dit que la ola la bière
au père et à la bière alors ça c'est
parce qu'on remonte vers une vers le
nord la frontière de belleville à la
bière c'est tout le coin site original
quand même une soupe à la bière alors ce
petit rohou cette citrouille comme vous
dites vous allez nous faire deux
recettes de mai alors qu'il ya des
choses qu'on ne voit plus tellement à ça
ça va partir de quelle famille oh là là
des cures cucurbitacées regardez les
mots que j'emploie la famille qui réunit
les courges des concombres et ses
énormes merveille ce très joli qui ont
une couleur fabuleuse ici on appelle ça
le cul voilà ça c'est plus la vidéo qui
est bon et alors vous m'avez dit vous
allez faire quelque chose de spécial
parce qu'on pouvait faire un repas de
fête
oui avec ce légume qui ne coûte que 3
france on le dira cbre hs alors l'a7
pour trois francs et un petit peu plus
avec les ingrédients c'est quand même
pas mal et que les pauvres à l'usan on
va ça ça va servir de soupir je vais là
décalotter je vais à creuser et tout le
la à la potée on va la mettre là dedans
et on à table regardez économie de
vaisselle et qu'on fait alors vous allez
me dire qu'avec ces cucurbitacées comme
vous dites oui et comme alexandre dumas
l'a écrit dans son grand livre de
cuisine même un curieux alors là on
inscrit sa sur un menu de fête la nappe
blanche est tout à fait un effet frais
joli bond alors les ingrédients qu'il
nous faut pour tout cela alors pour la
soupe à la bière bien entendu nous faut
du pain de la bière et du sucre en
poudre en poudre est je crois un peu de
cannelle
voilà pour une soupe au potiron il nous
faut des ricoh des petits cocos c'était
ses meilleurs c'est d'ailleurs le petit
oui après il nous faut du persil soir
chez du cerfeuil et en fer et versa
c'est parfait c'est la même famille et
il nous faut de l'oignon il nous faut du
rap et il nous faut de la crème fraîche
il nous faut du lait mais en plus grande
égalité quand même bien sûr il faudra
moment peu de sel et poivre
et puis le potiron notre cul voilà ce
que vous lui faites d'abord bon alors je
l'adopté décalotter est-ce que c'est
difficile maïté a des qualités
bon il faut faire attention de pas se
couper l'antenne c'est dur c'est dur il
faut enfoncer les photos et puis on fait
tourner bien que ça finisse eu un joli
chapeau voilà un joli chapeau alors l'a
fait vous voulez faire vend bien sûr
regardé ça c'est sur wii
alors là vous avez vidé la graine mais
vous avez laissé lasserre quoi cela sert
c'est fait c'est simple c'est pour ça
qu'il faut 2 deux citrouilles et quand
même
et oui une pour certains liquides
essentiel et l'autre qu'on a déjà débuté
en tronçons alors qu'est ce que vous
allez faire maintenant alors j'ai mis ma
poêle à chauffer avec un rien de graisse
penguins je vais y mettre un petit peu
d'oignons oui parce qu'il faut quand
même donner un petit peu dit faut élever
l'âge de trouille 87e qui peut sable un
petit peu grignoté va revenir là dedans
là réside et j'aurais pu tout à l'heure
à la présentation on a oublié les
ardeurs ce qui ne gâche rien à la
ventrèche alors on va remettre un petit
peu aussi
vous avez la rue là on va la mettre
parce que quand même s'ils améliorent le
google améliore le bourg que j'ai vu
beaucoup de recettes de soupe au potiron
n'y avait que le potiron s'annonce
terrible orange et carmen soupire ne
laisse qu'un départ la soupière
valeureuse n'ont pas et robin je vais
finir dollars ménard dont we will un
faux pas des masses mais ça n'est pas ça
dans le bon bout il y en a qui la
remettra pas mais il faut toujours
améliorer l'ordinaire
si on peut bien sûr bien sûr ce dont tu
fais pas comme une fortune d'aller
mettre un peu de la mmf même un peu de
jambon de bayonne ou et d'être ce qu'on
a sous la main
une autre voilà tout cas ça va aller
nourrir poil ça ça valait la hes-so
bâtir gentiment je vais juste savez un
tout petit peu parce que la voiture ce
n'est pas tellement sale et puis là ça
dépasse version la connaissent ils vont
se battre on peut l'acheter
passionné du tout on peut l'avantager
plus aléatoire ce jour n'est pas vendre
et se pressent devant alors alors même
que dans la bd henri louis la citrouille
à marquise la citrouille en morceaux on
va mettre tout cela dans une bonne
partie de la 50e si vous voyez pas ça
forme un tout petit comme pierre et là
vous allez j'imagine que vous aller
couvrir pour riom de jeu les eaux salées
et poivrées la citrouille parce que ces
douces oui et recouvrir
il faudra attendre peu près combien de
temps là on la demi-heure facilement une
demi-heure entre une demi heure et il
faut trois quarts d'heure il faut le
faire que ça dépend du potiron s'ils
font vite ou pas s'il est très mûr moins
de l'urma faut surveiller en survenue
alors ça nous laisse se sont peut-être
de commencer la soupe à la bière mais
bien entendu qu'est ce qu'il nous faut
mais pas grand-chose de l'oignon de la
farine de la cannelle de sucre
évidemment de la bière mais blonde s'est
pas tellement compliqué non bien comment
procéder voilà alors là j'ai déjà mis un
peu d'oignons à blondir tout doucement
dans un bled grave
voilà je vais en remettre un peu pour
vous faire plaisir avec oui là un petit
peu je remue oui là je vais y versez
dessus et son qi un tout petit peu de
farine en pluie a beaucoup et là
et les sessad aurait un tout petit peu
dans un tout petit peu plus la voie là
ils sont quelques uns un petit peu
couleurs combien la marine
oui pas beaucoup aux tout petits fours
et ensuite je regarde ça va comme vous
voilà très bien alors qu'est ce que vous
voulez maintenant la bière mais il faut
pas faire de la mousse et il faire
maintenant il faut faire tous deux
semaines voilà si vous mélangez tout ça
oui mais face à partir des mots parce
qu'elle a bien froide et la farine va
faire un peu de liant comme c'est bon
allez on ne va pas la matraque crois oui
très bien ce que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de farine faux pas mais la
contrainte robiquet quand même et
maintenant on va y mettre les aromates
alors un peu de sucre oui ma vie dit
elle peut on pas beaucoup parce que
quand même et oui tu peux pas te
souhaite une grande pensée vrai mais
quand bear et cannelle et de la cannelle
et de la cannelle joly on écorche oui
sauf un drôle de goût tout ce mélange
quand même hein c'est intéressant où il
le faut vous allez voir c'est amusant
d'essayer des choses nous voilà très
bien et on a ce bouillir oui un tout
petit peu quand même d'un minuscule bibi
exemple l'amour moins d'un mille auxerre
tout se mélange en laisse vous le
couvrit quand même non non on va le
laisser comme ça avoue les faits commis
et ben ça va nous laisser le temps de
finir la soupe à la citrouille alors le
potiron
il a cuit pendant 45 minutes oui avec
les oignons les petits lardons ça doit
être assez font du bien
non ni des comices au regard des sas et
c'est joli il faut qu'on puisse y
écraser à la fourchette ou une des
salles bien voilà deux mois et à
regarder ça sensible à la ja même pas
besoin de le passer ça s'écrase à tous
voilà regarder ça et j'ai mis mon lait à
chauffer darmon pour wii que voilà de sa
réunion
et oui ça s'écrase tout seul sur et puis
ça va finir de se mélanger encore
d'enlever père décédé pas bon alors là
je vis mon lait chaud chaud chaud
bon il échoit je vais vider cette purée
cette purée dedans et vous et laissez
les lardons
6 oh oui parce que ça donne le goût
oui bien sûr web et vous allez laisser
cuire encore combien de temps ça rend il
faut que ce soit un petit peu avec quand
même une bonne demi-heure encore une
bonne demi-heure mal de laisser cuire
sommes battus et vous allez le cuire à
couvert de nouveau là oui ça risque open
data fait non non non non non tout cela
il faut faire attention faut se regarder
moi ça si c'est joli et oui mais ça va
être bon ça apprendre joli coup là on va
encore un bon moment de cuisson ça va
nous laisser le temps peut-être
d'achever la sauva la bière mes bijoux
être à peu près comme il faut et de m
elle va arriver liste commune va pouvoir
regarder ça elle a pris à peu près une
demi heure louis aliot là rien les
treize jours et ce qui reste à faire
alors je convaincrai l'eau fraîche
mervans vous et vous vouliez saler
poivrer avant on peut merci pour me
l'aviez parler c'est vrai un peu de sel
un peu de poivre et j'espère oui je
n'étais pas beaucoup et du sel du poivre
je vais une cuillère de crème fraîche
oui et je l ai bien belle onctueuse
ça va et là surtout avait plus bouillir
maintenant il revient elle est arrêtée
et puis quoi d'autre bon vous allez me
donner le peur le voilà maïté merci je
vais faire qu'une autre tranche pascal
even
oui votre jolie part de rion des landes
c'est un bon boulanger jolie bien sûr il
le coupe en deux parce que là je n'aurai
pas à cela pour un autre marin vous avez
mis de la grèce qui est bien chaude là
là ça va griller instantanée vanillé bon
alors que dans l'autre souper bien les
prêtres et les prêtres je vais la
tournée parce qu'il faut pas que ça
brûle comme mon père est donc je laisse
un petit peu oui alors je vais mettre ma
soupe heures dans la salle à dire ça
dans la soupière
oui voilà mon père oui l'année
savez vous que ça sent très bon cette
soupe à la barre aux rares et
heureusement voix l'arrière 2-1 à la
jolie et sagna plus calmes être dedans
ça rattrape et non sur les auditions
quoi exactement
voilà c'est bon amplement
regardez ça comme ça grésille de bonheur
mais je vous dis que cet appétissant
et voilà ça y est alors séparé vite
notre soupe au potiron et bien je crois
qu'elle est presque prêt qui a encore un
petit quelque chose à finir voilà finir
après après non je voulais dire tout de
suite avant très bien le set se
comprendre oui alors elle est finie là
où il faut faire encore quelque chose je
l'arrêté on arrête le feu gym et la
crème fraîche
elle est belle
louette vos excellentes et c'est tout il
ya encore quelque chose à jouer hier le
voilà qu'on jouait le maître tour et
bien sûr il faut pas que ça bout à ce
moment-là nord parce qu'il va fondre le
mélange et dans d'autres sens voilà et
c'est bon et après et voilà et je veux
le verset leur masse ou pierre est très
bien alors vous l'amener ici oui voilà
alors vous m'enlevez le couvercle de la
soupière nez ça y est c'est fait et moi
la juste bon poids bonne mesure
vous savez pour inviter ses amis c'est
son dos un ozil est alors il faut encore
parsemée un peu de cerfeuil
oui j'en ai préparé exprès au poteau le
marin voilà terminé
eh bien vous savez ça alors là bâti à
tout le monde c'est joli alors la soupe
à la citrouille wind très jolie ou fois
les bennes original et belle vie à leur
apporter ça sur la table comme ça quand
on a ses copains d'idées oui ça commence
bien à fait c'est joli et puis la soupe
à la bière hier soir le résultat d'un
petit tour à la frontière belge
hommage à nos amis du nord de la france
si l'on regarde bien c'est très bon puis
c'est un sujet de conversation au début
d'europe 1 parce que c'est le nom donné
par lens l'accord exactement alors la
citrouille on la trouve partout dans
toute la france
quatre seulement de l'année tout ça
c'est pas cher c'est facile c'est
amusant alors pourquoi ne pas essayer à
vous et au revoir et à bientôt
au revoir et merci
[Musique]